[Applause]
so pleasure to be able to speak to you
tonight I've been coming to PI data for
a few years now it's nice to be able to
contribute something back so I thought
I'd begin with a question of why for
some of us it's kind of obvious but for
others is questioned maybe we should
just accept machine learning as a black
box and just get on with it I think your
background may help to explain your
point of view for those that others that
have worked in software engineering of
one form or another being able to
provide reasons to other people is
absolutely crucial how can anybody trust
what you're doing and when they have
questions what answers can you give well
that's just the way that it works as
machine learning finds its place in
healthcare or another very delicate and
sensitive areas that probably highlights
the reason why we need to have some kind
of answer but there are other reasons as
a software engineer when you're there in
the evening trying to figure out why
something isn't working
you're left with the question of why we
can't escape it so if we're putting
machine learning in to help maybe with a
decision support system we have to face
it and indeed as humans we have an
epistemic in other words a basic
knowledge seeking Drive it's also in the
motivation is it relevant am I wasting
my time so this brings me to this term
which maybe we can have a show of hands
who is familiar with this term of
hermeneutics not many well don't worry
there's an enormous amount of baggage
attached to it which we don't need to be
interested in but it's just the idea
that interpretation itself is
effectively subject to interpretation
but it's a studied field so there are a
few principles that I'd like to draw out
and then well maybe we'll see how they
relate to understanding machine learning
the first one is that
if it's not something we immediately
recognize then it's necessary to have if
you like more than one pass at the
subject whether that's a text or whether
it's data so expiratory data analysis
anybody you know by getting conversant
almost a dialog with the data we begin
to understand more there's also an idea
there that we need to compare the
particular with the general or the local
and the global at the sort of terms that
are floating around the machine learning
community the prediction and the model
and by looking at both that's where we
get the best understanding rather than
maybe just focusing in the past on model
level explanation or is is very trendy
at the moment prediction level both play
a role there's also an idea in
hermeneutics of fancily called a fusion
of horizons basically that you can bring
multiple points of view to bear and by
combining them then you get an enhanced
understanding it's pretty basic really
as an idea but sometimes it can be
missed over when people are just looking
at things in maybe hard statistical
terms and having given thought to
multiple points of view
so this is this idea that you go through
a spiral where you're comparing detail
and then backing out and thinking well
how does this relate to the whole and
that you integrate context to really be
effective because anything by itself can
mean almost anything but putting it into
a context that's where you start to pin
it down and that leads to real
understanding so let's focus on machine
learning interpretable machine learning
we've kind of got these two hopefully in
mind that there's the global which just
means the model and then there's the
local which is the individual prediction
so if a doctor was to say to you your
model why is it predicting that there is
cancer in this person this person this
set of data rather than how does this
model as a whole predict cancer that's
the kind of idea there's a lot of papers
being written and debate
but hopefully we can get past this about
these terms interpretability leaning
more to just understanding and explain
ability about really how would you
communicate that to someone now who that
someone is is critical if that someone
is a data scientist then you can come up
then with a whole ream of technical
information if that person is a domain
expert there's another perhaps
perspective as to what's technical if
that's a problem relating to structures
or if it's relating to finance again
domain expertise but if it's if you like
a layperson who is just maybe a subject
that's being affected by machine
learning then it's why have you been
turned out for your mobile phone
application why can't you get the credit
for the contract they don't want to hear
about area under the curve simple reason
codes it's really what we're looking for
so audience is crucial in this whole
process and that's what hermeneutics one
of the things they looked at is that the
audience is important who is heard of
this line ends up so maybe a quarter of
the audience who was actually installed
it and tried to use it almost as many
but not quite and that's probably the
best known of the interpretability
explain ability approaches now line was
a great great great breakthrough a
couple of years ago and its really this
idea that you can fit a nice linear
model fit the line in actually a very
complicated model space because you fit
lots of little ones so lime takes us
forward its focus is on the local the
individual prediction why is this
prediction being made now attorneys use
that it's agnostic is model agnostic in
other words in principle at least we can
use it where the gradient booster tree
you can use it with around forest music
with a neural network with a variety of
models that's the idea at least how does
it work well I just try to summarize the
basic idea is that it's
model on a model in as much as it looks
at the inputs going into the complex
model and the outputs and from that
tries to do create a simpler model does
this by perturbing the data fitting that
and then that becomes effectively your
coefficients and the beauty of it is
this just a few lines of code and we're
getting somewhere
this is the Boston dataset that you
might recognize and it's showing is
there that L stat is making a large
difference on this particular prediction
so you know what else that is you've got
some insight straight away we're beyond
the black box however it's been derived
because lime has made this sort of
linear assumption around it so that's
great but there are some problems
there's already always our round there
and these come down to a few areas one
is of course that in this model that's
complicated and we're drawing our little
lines through it sometimes even at the
detail level they're not linear at all
you can have some very crazy sort of
boundaries in the decision space so
there are issues with how wide that
little kernel is that it's using to try
and establish where the boundaries so
some researchers have gone in and
they've found some very contradictory
ideas by digging through so lime is
great but it comes with a caution
there's also the thought that a linear
model is never going to be too good by
itself in modeling the feature
interactions which often lead to the
complexity there's also a question about
how in practice how long it takes so if
you're looking for a real time
application where you're down two
milliseconds of response time your
engineers may have a challenge on their
hands there are approaches where you can
engineer it h2o I've done that by
establishing the k-means towards the
line predictions one good thing about
lime is the fact that it because it's an
another model by itself it also has got
some probability of its prediction so
you've got the usually a probability on
your complex model so it says about this
80% certain
and then line can come along and say
well I'm 70%
about my prediction which a lot of
approaches don't have but that should be
a warning because then there's all that
uncertainty effectively there which
could be misleading you
so already lime is being packaged into
commercial products and so on it's a
little bit fearful if they're going to
be passed on to people in the gdpr
scenario of this is the answer when in
fact unless they highlight the
uncertainty it may not be the answer
so lime is good but there are caveats
what else is there I wanted to draw
attention to this package been a bit
problematic getting it to run but that's
largely because it draws in a lot of
other packages even out it would seem to
are it's pulling those in and what he's
trying to do is not just give you just
line which he'll I five does and as I
said it's quite a few other ones but
also some other approaches so one of
them is that it can create a surrogate
decision tree so again we're building a
model based on a complex model but in
this case it's a tree now trees as we
know are kind of up to a point
inherently interpretable
everybody can generally think about how
there's splits around questions and that
the more important ones hopefully come
first and then you make your way through
so here's just the text representation
again I think this is Boston of how that
could work this may not be very good for
the layperson but for somebody with some
technical understanding of this subject
this might be quite good gives them
quite a bit of information about what
was more important and how the
combinations sort of build along and it
can work with regression unlike this
laptop can also work the classification
well we lost the slide but there was
just another tree showing that it can do
that skater also has this other feature
that it can try and generate a bayesian
rules list around subject so this is a
very different approach but what you can
see there I think this is Titanic
probably is that it's going through and
building based on its assessment of the
data a series of rules again so again
it's a fairly interpretive approach
assuming the rules list is not
there's certainly a lot better than well
this is a black box and you just have to
take it on trust
so skater offers a few possibilities if
you can get through the install process
this I pop this slide in just to show
that these models this is the bayesian
rules list approach they're not
necessarily greatly inferior to complex
approaches so at least from a
statistical point of here view here
you've got your area under the curve and
the random forest and the Bayes rule
bayesian rule lists they're actually
quite comparable so that maybe changes
some of our assumptions around some of
these other approaches and we'll look at
one or two more as we go now chap who's
loaded this one ok so almost as many as
lime and that's kind of what I've been
finding talking to people over the last
year or so so I found this last year and
at the time it was quite limited but
slumber'd the developer in University of
Washington I think has been very busy
and he's been adding a number of
approximations to Sharpe to make it work
so Shockley values come amazingly enough
from game theory and it's all about the
idea that you can have groups working
together and you need to find a way to
pay off appropriately and it's basically
done in the mathematical way by
assessing all of the groups and then
working out all the possibilities and
then saying across all of those this is
your feature contribution so this is
actually a pulled in two features in a
machine learning sense and there are
theoretical guarantees but as with all
of these things I'm not sure they're
quite what they seem so that's why I put
in the line at the bottom I've not
tested this in in practice but I'm
fairly sure that if you've got a lot of
highly correlated data then it's going
to end up sharing that payoff between
lots of feet is so kind of skewing so if
you've done some preceding feature
selection then you use shap that could
probably well lead to quite an accurate
result and shop can do many things as I
said basically shop is actually several
different little products under the hood
this is focusing on the tree shop
because sharply values themselves are
highly expensive to compute
and basically would have to be
disregarded so what the researchers have
done it come up with useful
approximations in the classic
mathematical way so here we see at the
top an individual so the local
prediction and you see it's nicely
broken down you can see what's driving
it one way and what's driving it the
other and by using the width there you
can see that what's the more important
so in terms of this is the adult census
I think what's actually driving it in
this instance is the relationship to not
in family so that's looking at it as an
individual but criticism of looking at
individual predictions is starting to
build up now as people realize that's
not necessarily very representative it
helps you with the individual one but
let's say from a regulatory point of
view you want to view the whole thing
how well does this system work and for
that you need a bit more so this looks
here at the first thousand of these
predictions and sort of terms the thing
on its side and you get to see visually
an idea of what's contributing and then
you can dig into the details so very
good in addition to that by just
averaging up the whole lot you get a
global interpretability score in terms
of feature contributions so basically
for no extra cost you've got local and
global I put this slide in just to
highlight something that the author of
this package drew attention to recently
in a blog post and that's that
traditional feature importance methods
that are available in just certain
methods like say random forests or in
this case a gradient booster tree where
there is a feature importance kind of
can give you a false security that you
can interpret your model I mean maybe
you've done this in the past you've
worked through and you just have a quick
look at the feature importances but
actually when you look at those
side-by-side you realize they're all
different depending on what metric you
use so how reliable are they so because
he's promoting Chappy's is drawing
attention that in theory the Shapley
values assuming the caveats we spoke
before are more consistent and will give
you something like a true work
set of global feature contributions -
something to bear in mind if you've been
just going with your Genie scores
there's a bit more to it and nicely in
the package you can even start to see
these things together in a single plot
so here you've got the global
perspective but by using the width and
also the density of the dots you begin
to see for instance at the capital gain
skews things because it's very important
in some but actually relationship wins
out because there's more data clump to
it so it maybe has less of effect in the
individual predictions but overall the
aggregate value is there so very simple
you see one line of code you've got that
insight so Shapps probably a package to
really investigate and here's a nice
thing if you're running the most recent
versions of these libraries the
developers have included it they can see
the value of these Shapley values or at
least the tree approximation of them
this is something that's coming to them
for a bit more is again people outside
the traditional machine learning are
starting to give their perspectives and
in the whole sort of bayesian world of
prediction is the thought of causality
and they say well really you should take
account of the counterfactual so I found
this recently I guess more of a
development idea that somebody's put
together called contrastive explanation
where you have the fact and the foil and
it just reminded me of this saying that
I've come across in the past this is a
teacher of maybe a couple of hundred
years three hundred years ago who made
this point that basically it's
understanding the differences between
things
is when you really know them if you
can't tell the difference you don't know
them so what it is able to do is look at
this individual prediction and say it's
this instead of this and then give its
reasons so to the domain expert who's
got that kind of implicit knowledge this
could be quite meaningful because the
doctor knows that you've got a fine
gradient and maybe this might convince
him yes I'll go ahead so this is the one
to look out for and there's a nice paper
that's been recently produced this is
another package and then it came across
recently that can help us with global
contributions I think it's by greedy
approximation that it works it out but
ultimately you get the global picture
and again but this was only about ten
lines of code it was able to give us a
breakdown of what's really important and
it's good to see that else that confirms
what we saw before so it's another
package and because of this thought in
in her home you knew ticks about the
need to have different perspectives and
see do they agree how much have we got
in common are we missing something over
here
this couldn't be another useful tool
Rafi is a completely different approach
this is trying to build a model that's
interpreted well rather than just add it
on afterwards as we saw with these other
methods so it does this by first of all
working off the standard features adding
in some more through generating decision
trees and then from that trying to work
out the interactions because again we're
back to that problem that the linear
model is great but it doesn't really
know interactions but roof it tries to
take you beyond that the package I found
is not very well documented but the idea
is very powerful because you can get
high I've seen in comparison I think
with the r version where it was kind of
comparable to random forests at least
with certain datasets so this could be
very useful not only to give post-hoc
interpretability but actually a whole
model that maybe you could do more
rigorous testing on and as you can see
again it's not much code the one thing I
did notice a huge number of rules were
created so that would probably require
some post processing to see which are
the really important ones I just picked
out a couple that stood out from the
list else tagging there are there are
many more packages often driven by
papers that you can find an archive some
new some old nonconformist is related to
the conformal prediction idea from
robust statistics and already that's
starting to be used in some places is a
bit more complicated
but seems to offer some good guarantees
law is this another approach toward
local explanations but looking at a more
of a region level rather than the
individual or the global and l 2x is an
information theoretic so it's looking at
mutual information
and working out how that can help us to
see what's the more important parts and
if you know about I think it's
variational bottleneck and all of that
stuff that there's plenty more I'd a
chat with Matt Dale in the other day and
anyway there are many approaches many
possibility potential views in how to
interpret another thing just to mention
briefly actually boost because it has it
is this idea of monotonicity what is it
well this simple diagram tries to
capture it the linear model makes its
over each trend the complex model tries
to fit all of the data including the
noise but actually sometimes you just
want a simpler representation so for
instance if the likelihood is on the Y
scale and say distance is on the X then
you don't really want it to go up as
that goes further away that's just noise
so a monotonic model can be quite useful
for something like that that brings me
to deep networks all the rage of course
and here also this idea is being
exploited so this is a library that's
recently been released tensor flow
lattice that applies it in a neural
network context I mean there's so much
stuff in the neural network area I've
just picked out a few here they explore
very different ideas but on how to open
those boxes so this sort of media storm
about these things are unreachable
actually it's not really true there's a
lot that can be drawn out so this is an
idea if you're interested in this space
to go and research there are tons of
papers that basically come back to this
thought and it's distinguishing salient
see with gradients and sensitivity which
are probably is a bit more related to
just perturbing inputs from a really
more important concept which is
relevance because just because something
changes doesn't mean that that's
actually the important thing so read
away there's plenty on this and and
there's actually some stuff on github
that you'll find exploring it including
just to go back that investigate is
where somebody's actually tried to put
several approaches together because you
can read all these papers and be nowise
or at the end of it but that's a fairly
useful project that someone's done so
just to mention in passing our primary
channel of information is of course
if we have sight our eyes and there are
some great tools appearing and being
developed so you're probably heard of
these these familiar partial dependents
plot no not really just a few hands well
that gives you the average but you
really need to see it with this other
one the individual conditional
expectation and then you can see how the
different ones relate and if they crissy
criss crossing then you've got a problem
bit deeper yellow brick I think Ian has
highlighted this in the past but it's
developing at an amazing rate there's
all kinds of visualizations in there
some of the data some of the model but
all sort of like to call out this Kepler
mapper which is bringing something from
topological data analysis far too
complicated to talk about here but might
be worth particularly if you're
concerned that in a transformation
you're losing the real structure and
relationship because this is a much more
kind of elastic approach just to mention
are even in a pine Python meetup because
there's some very interesting things in
our I mean there's a box obviously
because of the academic links but fast
and frugal trees I got onto this through
the professor at Southampton
Konstantinos did a presentation about
basically sometimes we're choosing the
wrong kinds of models and sometimes a
simple model can be just as good
literally almost from a theoretic point
of view and there's also this gamsol one
which graphing goes back to hasty a
great kind of practitioner product is
this Daleks continuing the Doctor Who
reference which has got lots and lots of
plots some of them that can actually go
beyond partial dependence and individual
conditional expectation such as the ones
mentioned there so if you're really
interested in just trying to get a
visual grip on your data have a look one
more thing isn't this all too much we've
got enough time for what we've got to do
now well Google have just released this
what-if tool that tries to draw together
a lot of these ideas and if you're not
so hot in your coding skills you can
actually do this through a user
interface so exploring your data
exploring your model very interesting
I'd say it's worth a look so what have
we looked at
well first of all try to combine
multiple techniques I think we all tend
to look for the one magic technique when
actually what we should be doing is
seeing which group maybe I should use a
surrogate tree and then explore the
details with some plots so I'm getting
the global and the local and getting
that deeper understanding and also don't
expect to do it in one go again we want
the quick answer but hermeneutic
principles to think about and of course
we just really talked about models but
interpretability particular from a
regulatory point of view could look at
the whole pipeline and is their
provenance and so on and just to come
back to the thought that all of these
packages they're not really primetime
yet they're great efforts and they're to
be applauded and supported but you might
more your mileage may vary so have a
look and see whether maybe more needs to
be done so thank you
thank you very much team we've got time
for a couple of questions do we have
questions thank you very much
one thing that I've been really
interested in recently and something
I've been using a lot is essentially
really deep ensemble models to be able
to essentially increase the accuracy by
just having lots of generative models
with these different techniques which
libraries do you think work best with
ensemble models stuff like stacktrace
and stuff like that all those different
things lime because of its ignorance its
agnosticism generally will work with
most things but we'll take it with a
pinch of salt what you're getting out
Shapley if it's a tree based on sambal
might be quite useful for you so I don't
think ensembles are necessarily ruled
out would this be useful for these tools
be useful for understanding how these
adversarial attacks are disturbing the
system and what could be done to make
the systems the models more robust well
I think there's a strong overlap in the
research community because it's that
probabilistic
kind of where is my border issue that
feeds into both that suddenly there's a
you know you've fallen off the manifold
into another area and the same thing can
happen with the classification so I know
research is definitely driving at that
to try and make it more robust sometimes
by including both techniques at once but
I'd say a lot of it is still at that
kind of research paper stage but it's
probably going to develop as to how a
model is interpretable and robot
more question from a regular regulation
perspective have you seen any of these
techniques kind of have a favorable or
unfavorable reaction when talking being
spoken about their regulatory context
well I haven't really got first-hand
experience but I know when I went to a
conference where it was discussed in
some detail apparently the output that's
already provided it can be quite a
technical kind of dump that's being done
with the existing modeling so the
requirements I think there's so much to
be established there that probably the
safest approach is to provide the most
again multiple models and let the
experts decide rather than trusting that
the model you know the machine learning
model is somehow magically correct okay
I think we'll wrap up Dean's talk then
move on to the Lightning's please thank
[Applause]